um
so thank you uh to the organizers for uh
putting together such a wonderful
workshop until today i guess
um
and so i'm going to try my best to
contribute to it as well the paper that
i want to present today today's joint
work with sono bernardi from mit and
alex smallin who is a graduate student
who is finishing his speech
this year at yale
the title selling experiments refers to
experiments in the sense of blackwell
that is
we want to think about providing
statistical information
in
the sense of experiments
as blackwell formulated it and what
we're interested in in particular is how
to
package information
and how to price information
okay
we think about
basically
a problem between uh two sides the the
data seller
um who wants to offer his data that he
has available to a data buyer uh who's
really your standard
base in decision maker
who faces a problem of a decision
process under uncertainty and he goes
into this decision
already with some partial information
that might inform him but there's always
a possibility of acquiring some
additional information
thus augmenting his own private
information
so as to make an even better and
informed decision
and from the data sellers point of view
the question is how do i want to provide
this additional information at what
price do i want to provide it
and given that the data buyers come in
with their own
luggage in some sense their own history
their own information the question is
whether i want to provide different
pieces of information to different
buyers
and given that i'm providing different
information do i possibly want to offer
it at different prices
across a variety of possible buyers
okay
and so the leading example that
helped alessandro meet
was to think about it but also to
motivate the question
um is simply
how do i provide access to large
databases as they are prevalent on the
internet so think about
data brokers such as axiom and bluecry
but i'm also google in ad exchange
basically providing information for
advertisers in terms of narrowing
framing
fragmenting large parts of of their
their own proprietary database
sort of a specific example to keep in
mind throughout the talk think about
behavioral retargeting right so
here the idea is that firms want to make
a basically want to provide tailored
advertising to
uh customers customers that actually
have been on their website before so
that's why it's why it's retargeting uh
the advertisers have already some
information
about the
the characteristics the attribute of the
consumer that they're facing
but in order to know how far they should
go and how specific the advertising
should be
it probably helps them to acquire some
additional information third-party
information from one of these large
databases
how valuable that information is of
course will depend on how good their own
databases how much information they
already know about the consumer
we're going to think about
the data seller is providing an
information product okay that's really
sort of
an experiment in the sense of blackwell
and what it will do is to basically
augment the information that the
decision maker already has
with
further
additional information incremental
information about the the payoff
relevant state
the issue here is that the value that
that experiment provides to the decision
maker will of course depend
um on his own information that is to
what extent he's already informed about
the the decision that he has to make
okay and to the extent that that is this
private information
the question is how can i elicit that
information how can i uh find the right
match between the incremental
information that the data seller can
offer and the information that the data
buyer
already possesses okay
okay so now you see that
we'll go basically a little bit in the
direction of trying to
find the optimal price find the optimal
match in terms of the product and
eliciting the private information so the
language that should be familiar to you
in terms of mechanism design so what
we're trying to do is to think about how
to design information in terms of what's
the nature of the experiments that we
want to provide and then second how do
we should be price individual
experiments individual
accesses to the database okay
um sort of the the take that we're going
to have here is that the the seller can
really just contract
on the information that he's provided
he cannot contract or ask for
commissions on the eventual action that
the data buyer purchases okay so that's
a little different if you wish from
um
from auction for sponsored search we're
basically providing information as well
as a product here we're simply selling
just the information product itself
and so
some of the results are going to show
that it will be optimal
to basically offer from the data sellers
point of view a menu that is
a whole class of experiments
and then we're going to try to
characterize what these experiments look
like okay
the two main results that i want to
sure today is that first of all
experiments will be or the items on the
menu that is the experiments
are going to be simple in a sense that
they will only use a limited uh signal
space
but then also the menu itself that is
the collection of experiments that we're
going to offer is going to be course in
the sense that it's going to be a much
smaller cardinality
as would be indicated by the diversity
or the the heterogeneity in terms of the
bias
and then
um
i'd probably have a little bit time to
think about what are the distortions
information and how do we get how do we
screen different buyers uh by means of
matching their prior information with
augmenting information and sort of that
will be direct information
just to get some intuition uh so if if
the data buyers if all different types
want totally different things
no i can completely price discriminate
them by
giving them just the information that
they need which would be useless to the
other ones which would seem to
go against this intuition that you would
have or this statement that you would
have very few
very good so um
the the piece i think that you're
referring to uh vince's um
the interaction among the buyers of the
information okay we're not going to look
at any interaction
after the acquisition of information we
simply think of one
particular buyer wanting information for
a particular decision problem
where the
interaction is going to come from
is that different buyers have different
quality of private information already
and to the extent that i have better
private information already i'm less
willing to pay for the additional
information provided okay
clearly from the point of view of the
data seller the data buyer who is
ignorant or uninformed is sort of the
best buyer because he has the highest
value to the experiment everybody else
will have a lower value of experience so
what i'm going to try to do is to screen
to separate in some sense buyers who
already have a lot of information from
those who have very little information
so will that be single dimensional
no that will be that is going to you
will see information is typically very
high dimensional okay
um
this is really not to document
my knowledge but rather my ignorance in
the sense that
i think there's sort of a big
a lot of questions surrounding
information the value of information
how to think about the value of
databases and so on and i i would like
to learn more
especially on what's been done in that
respect in in computer science and
theoretical computer science and i
couldn't find very much so this is
really just
um sort of a sample of the literature
and economics
okay so let me um describe you the model
which is uh which is going to be fairly
standard we think about the single
decision maker that's the data buyer
and they are going to be finite state
the finite set of states of the world
uh as finite set of actions
and
the state together with the action that
the decision maker is going to take is
determining his utility exposed okay
the leading example that i will
throughout the talk
it's a particular simple one where the
objective for decision makers really to
matching the action to the state okay if
i match the action with the states so
simply think of action state space
basically of the same cardinality
enabled according to the same indices
then i get a payoff of one
if i fail to match with my action the
state simply because i don't have enough
information i got unlucky then i have a
payoff of zero okay
the generalizations you will see
won't require much work but
the formulas are going to be
particularly easy and transparent
if i'm going to stay with this matching
action state formulation okay
so
this is probably way too much notation
but all i want to say is that yes
but you want to match the stage
simply uh you know this is the general
set up we want to just label the actions
from one to n label these states from
one to n and what the decision maker is
to choose if he were to know the state
omega one uh he should choose a one when
the state is omega one a two when the
state is omega two
these are just a generic description of
action and state so
for the example and for the calculations
that you will see
okay
um
right so we want to stay a start
basically with the bayesian framework
that we say the states
have some distribution uh that's what we
refer to as a common prior but the
decision maker when he makes his
decision uh may have some uh prior
information let's call this uh his
initial belief or his internal belief
that is being generated through some uh
signal process so what is important here
is that basically the initial belief
that each individual decision maker has
when he comes into the process is
informed by the signal r and that leads
him to adopt
a an interim belief over the possible
states of the world because that's how
he enters this decision problem okay
from the point of view of the data
seller the database
um
this problem presents itself that
there's a distribution of buyers in the
world who have a distribution of
possible beliefs and that's given by f
of theta
okay so the data seller doesn't know
what the belief of a particular data
buyer is how much information he has
already but he has a statistical
information given by that
belief f of theta which is in use by the
prior and by the nature of the
initial signal structure
and the additional information that you
can provide has precisely the same
structure as initial signal in the sense
that an experiment so that's the formal
definition that we're going to adopt
an experiment which consists of a signal
space capital s and a likelihood
function pi is simply mapping the
generate as a function of the true state
a probability distribution over the
signals
okay
and we're going to assume
that the generation of the type and the
information structure is conditionally
independent so that the joint
distribution basically is just the
product of the marginals
do you allow for signals to be
correlated with valuation
absolutely
oh absolutely
right again the initial signal is a
mapping from the state into
the signal space so that's a sense in
which this is prior information
otherwise it wouldn't
make sense right
it's before you condition on s right so
so so you know that uh the in the market
there are data buyers who have varying
degrees of private information that's
described by app of theta okay
and so
um
from the point of view of the data
seller the
uh choice is that he is now offering
is basically set of possible experiments
that's the menu so
uh script is basically a set of possible
information structures or experiments
and a particular experiment is simply a
capital i and each one of this
experiments is offered at the price
t
okay
so
um
so important we don't we are not allowed
to contract either on the action on the
final realization of the space so
typical scoring rules the belief
elicitation
are simply not available we can simply
price the information or price the
experiment okay so the timing
um is the following one the type of
decision makers realize so his interim
information
he then can make a choice out of this
menu of experiments for every experiment
that he's purchasing he has to pay a
price
and after he chose the experiment he's
simply going to observe a signal
realization
is the
information provided or unconstrained
and what types of signals he can
generate or yes he does an initial
signal and he can only garble that
for all that we do today we basically
have him so think about this completely
unconstrained so he can condition on
omega so think basically there's this
large database that is pre-installed
there's no
cost of either having or not providing
information i'm just simply choosing how
to okay right so
i don't have time for the interpretation
but but just to make okay good so um
so how it should be think about this
um from the point of view of the
decision maker if you were to make a
decision just on the basis of his
partial information his interim
information all he could do is to form
a conditioning given his
initial type theta and he would then
choose the best action
that would maximize his expected utility
okay
now if he is being provided with an
experiment
okay then he realizes that he can do
better than what he could do uh without
the experiment okay and how can you do
better well besides conditioning on the
theta he can also condition on the
signal
okay
uh and the difference and after taking
the expectation to get the expected
value of the experiment from his point
of view and the difference between these
two is simply the value of the
experiment from the point of view of the
decision maker and that is what is he
what is he willing to to pay in some
sense to have access to that additional
information
this is not negative absolutely right
because
um i can always discard the additional
information and just do right so
we kind of assume that one of the menu
items is to pay nothing for nothing
for them sorry and remember here we
haven't yet had any prices so this is
really just the gross value of the
experiment provided yeah and that is not
negative
okay
um good so
just to have a little a bit of a handle
what it is that we're talking about the
interim probability is basically just a
belief about any particular state
realization the experiment is really
just a likelihood function that tells me
given the true state what's the
likelihood that a particular signal is
realized and so therefore we can think
about a particular experiment simply as
a matrix pi that conditional on the
state omega so that's the row
generates different signals
interests i mean specific experiments
that we'll refer to and that will be
your views
uh one is um
locally and noise free one is the one
where we basically
provide with the signal sj just
information about one state so that
means there's no noise in the signal
once that signal is received i know that
your true state is i right
if you look at the entries
from the row side then
if it's just zeros with the exception of
one one then we refer to this as locally
non-dispersed because it basically means
that the information that we provide
about omega i is non-dispersed it's
concentrated just on one signal
okay and of course a perfectly
informative experiment is one that has
just once on the diagonal and zero of
the diagonal so that's one that is
globally
noise free and
non-dispersed okay
so here's why you see now why it's a
little bit helpful or useful
um to
in the presentation focus on the
matching action and state because given
that we have that assumption that it's a
payoff so either one or zero
we can really
describe the value of the experiment in
a very compact form
that is
i'm simply going to think for every
signal
that are observed so these are the j's
i'm going to choose
that action that has the highest
posterior likelihood and the posterior
likelihood is simply the prior times the
likelihood
right
and i'm going to do this for every
signal
and of course there's a probability of
signals but
in the bayesian framework it all cancels
out so this is really the value of the
experiment
and to the right
is what i would do in the absence of the
experiment in the absence of additional
information i would simply choose that
state that has the highest prior
probability and the difference is simply
the value of the experiment
so
what are we talking about therefore the
allocation problem that we're interested
in is the one
where we provide a random allocation
because the signals
are random right and in fact the
valuable
allocations have to be random because
they want to be tailored to the state
okay
um
and the agent is essentially one that
has unit demand because he's choose to
choose one out of the
uh and actions
okay
so that is that's the problem that that
we're looking at okay so should i
understand these matching experiments as
providing a basis for computing
more general utilities absolutely all
that would happen here
is you would multiply this instead of
one with the utility differences from
switching action so so that it would all
go through it's just then the much more
elaborate formulation
okay
so
just to get a little bit of geometry
if i'm starting out with a posterior
belief uh in a three state space so
theta one theta two and and one minus
that
as the interim belief then i can ask
myself what is the value
of a perfectly experiment and that's
basically a mountain with three faces
the edges represent the fact that we are
switching given the prior or the the
interim belief we would switch the
action to one that is more appropriate
and clearly the most
uh value is being touched by that person
who has the least informed um
prior or interim belief
okay
so here's the formal problem that we
therefore set out
we want to offer many of experiments
we're going to look at a direct
mechanism
and really what we want to do is to
maximize the revenue from the seller's
point of view the revenue for the
database so you don't see any cost of
providing information here
and the two things i need to be worrying
about is that
i want to get incentive compatibility
so that when i'm type theta i'm not
trying to get an experiment that's meant
for somebody else
and i'm also have to satisfy
participation constraints so that the
net value after paying for that
information structure has a value larger
than
zero
okay so let's
dive right in get sort of a few results
um
right so
we have think about it we even though we
have just a finite state of the world uh
the beliefs are basically continuum
right because these are the beliefs
about uh that i have about state one c2
and so on
and from the states i'm going to
generate signals i'm going to take
action so that's potentially complicated
the first uh thing to cut this through
is to say well actually um an optimal
experiment will never have to have more
signals than the action to takes because
after all what is the signal it's really
providing me with a recommendation of to
choose an optimal action
okay and therefore i can always reduce
the dimensionality of the signal space
down to the action space
in fact typically that will improve
the value that i'm providing because
if i provide more signals then these are
basically more opportunities to deviate
and so if i'm compactifying it in a
sense that
for the truth telling person i'm going
to combine all signals that will lead to
the same action anyway but i'm keeping
his utility constant but the
misreporting utility necessarily has to
go down because i'm removing options
okay
so
i'm a little surprised because you'd
need to make a action recommendation for
every different type of yes
right why is it the cardinality of
actions rather than actions cross types
remember i'm talking here of the every
experiment
right
right so every type is going to just one
experiment and for that experiment
so with that
um
just to give you illustration right so
if you you know now to the binary site
binary action case
uh where the utility function is simply
that
for this is the first proposition allows
us to basically look now also just as
binary information structures
okay um and without of loss of
generality we can think about the
diagonals here
as being larger than one so that we sort
signal belonging to state yes
and now we want to know how do we choose
that information structure
simply you should just
give recommend the action recommendation
to the buyer because if you talk more
information
that's exactly so it's not it's not a
difficult result that's sort of a result
that it's in the beijing persuasion
lectures as well right
that's the minimal information i need in
order to choose the right action and
there's no reason to give more
information than that
i understand that
each different type is choosing a
different experiment for my menu then i
certainly understand the intuition that
there should only be at most
a number of action you know uh
cardinality of signal space
but i thought you said that the
um
that we were going to end up with a much
coarser set of experiments yes many
types are going to be choosing the same
experience yes and so that proposition
doesn't address that yet at all
right because we just think about every
single experiment so do you okay so wait
a little okay
so so this is an information structure
now right so we can ask in this little
information structure
what is
a locally non-dispersed and what is a
locally noise free information structure
this information structure has the
property
that it's both okay
and let's just pause for a moment and
see what this um
information structure does do
um
it basically gives me
noise free information on the high
signal because tells me without doubt
i'm getting um i'm in this in the high
state uh whereas here clearly i have
noisy information okay
um but
what is important is that that
particular information structure while
it does look informative it's actually
valuable only for that agent
who assigns a high probability
to omega l
because in the absence of information he
would have chosen the action that is
relevant for omega l
okay and now he has sort of clear
evidence that against his prior he has
he has sometimes a reason to choose the
action that is relevant for the high
state
where somebody who had assigned a high
probability
to the high state okay would find this
experiment completely without value
because
under both signalization he would still
stay with this commitment to the high
action okay so that means
that the value of information from a
particular experiment
differs across different buyers okay and
in some sense this is just
a reflection of the fact that the
ordering that blackwell suggested is
highly incomplete okay and we're using
this incompleteness of the ordering here
to basically screen
buyers according to their willingness to
pay because they rank information
differently and that allows us to
actually screen them
okay
so here is just a plot
um
of the binary state okay so the we come
in with the prior probability theta
about the probability being
that the state is high
and i'm going to provide
a perfectly informative signal that has
entries 1 on the diagonal and i'm asking
myself what is the value of that
experiment okay
so
clearly it is
very high for the uninformed guy which
has a split prior
and then it's declining in both
you
directions
not i think you should normally type two
and alpha and beta are the error
probabilities not the not
so i would use the
different labels yes thank you
the common in statistics you use exactly
the opposite
not only do i show my ignorance in
computer science but also in statistics
thank you very much
that was very simple okay
i'm happy okay but what i do want to
point out even sticking with the alphas
and beaters um
so here we have now an experiment that
it's not perfectly informative okay and
what you see here is that the value of
the experiment on both sides of one half
is different okay
this is an an experiment that is
valuable for the low type so low signals
low probabilities on the high states but
not so valuable on the right hand side
so so what we immediately see
is that just the
distance from being uninformed is not
a sufficient statistic anymore it's not
sufficient information to evaluate the
value of experiment and a sort of an
indication of the of the incompleteness
of the ranking okay that we're going to
make uh use of okay
but i i guess i want to at least use
sort of geometry here to to make two
additional points
if you think now about
even here already
this as in
incentive problem
uh you'll notice that there are quite a
few things different from
from a standard problem okay in the
sense that the highest type
is actually the interior rather than the
boundary okay incentive constraints
run down locally to the left and to the
right okay
and participation constraints are not
just on one side of the
mechanism but also on the other side
okay so this is as an as a as a
mechanism design problem it's sort of
unusual in a sense that
um it's not just a local incentive
constraint it's not just local
participation constrained that bind
and it's also
evidence in some sense of the high
dimensional here of information and we
given that really our prior varies just
in the one dimension
there is differentiation provided by the
information both horizontally as well as
vertically and we can't separate these
two okay they basically come
through bayes law uh automatically both
in horizontal and vertical
differentiation okay
um
let me just give you a little bit of a
sense of of the general results but
staying
illustratively with the binary
uh binary state okay so with a binary
state we can really
express everything in terms of the prior
and
the informativeness
of the information structure and so we
can think about beta here as the
baseline informativeness and alpha minus
beta of the relative informativeness
between one of the two signals okay
so that we can plot the feasible set of
experiments
um as as follows and we can ask given
what the value of the experiment is what
are the
the indifference curve what are the
directions in which i would like to
improve
um
the value okay
and and the important point here is that
if i keep the relative informativeness
constant and just increase the baseline
informativeness of the experiment
then actually we see an increase in the
utility across all types
okay so that means optimal information
structure necessarily going to
force us
onto the boundary here okay
uh which basically means
that we know even though we haven't yet
determined where on the bound are we
going to
be for different types we're definitely
going to be at the boundary
boundary here in terms of alpha beta
simply meant
that we're going to provide
non-dispersed information structures
okay and so this is
uh indeed the sort of the main
characterization
um for finitely many states in action
and allowing for continuum of types in
terms of the beliefs
that says
first
we always going to offer
the fully experiment fully informative
experiment that is the one that has
diagonals
um
that's always going to be part of the
optimal menu okay
but then any other experiment okay
we'll have to have the feature that it's
locally non-dispersed okay that is there
will be at least one row there that has
just zeros and one okay
and that's basically
um all that can be said
about the uh the case of um
of the general setup
and the
um
the additional result in terms of the
uh yeah
general result including sort of general
utility functions exactly so nothing
would change exactly yeah
because it's the it's this drive towards
the boundary and to the maximum
separation that gets you
this locally non-dispersed yes but it
doesn't get you more than that
basically and now we have sort of a few
options that we can do
okay that is i can try to develop a
little bit of the intuition
uh by choosing simpler example and give
you sort of partial results or sort of
more complete con sort of
characterizations and more exact
solutions
okay
so i have a couple of questions so here
you're assuming that after the mechanism
is run there's no sharing of information
across
buyers no it has just a single buyer but
the instances of that buyer in terms of
different types okay so there's no
interaction of the buyers afterwards at
all so that's
that's an interesting direction of
course to think about yeah another
question so here uh you're also assuming
that uh the utility function so the
buyer has a single uh utility function
you're not considering the case where
there's a
where the buyers drawn from a population
where different people might have
different utilities so the only
heterogeneity that comes in here is from
the heterogeneity induced information
absolutely and so
in statistics
who invited him
you get the measurement result for
example and then you have to trade one
error against the others yes and so
normally they are the curve so alpha and
beta are not dependent
independent they are on a curve and
that's the quality of the experiment so
to speak how close it is to revealing so
normally you can say
you can only i mean create one of one um
given one experiment yes
the other so i i
okay so
so what i thought you were going to go
how do i choose the errors that is in
some sense type one error versus type
two error exactly uh in the experiment
since it's just i mean since it's an
experiment in the sense of blackwell we
are uncons there's no we don't face any
constraints in terms of choosing the
alphas and betas apart from you know
they're being well defined
but but it is a choice of how do i want
to how do i want to place type 1 and
type 2 errors okay and so that's um
what are maybe sort of the second to
last results that i want to show so um
let me stay for the moment with just
binary states
okay so uh they're just two types of
possible buyers theta ellen sita low
but there are many states in many
actions
okay so
uh so that information could lead me to
take one out of n possible actions
and let me now order the states
by their ranking in terms of the
likelihood ratios okay so
i'm simply having the two types
there are some states that need more
likely by the high type okay
and there's some states that are deemed
more likely by the law type and i can
rank them
okay and now i'm going to ask
essentially how do i use that ranking of
the initial priors
in order to provide information
okay
and so um
the
result that falls in is then
that we have two types one type is going
to get full information the perfect
experiment the other one is getting to
have a noisy experiment okay and the
noisy experiment is going to have the
structure
that it's not going to provide them with
any information
about the lower states which he deemed
unlikely
and is going to provide him
with non-dispersed information on the
states that he deems more likely okay
we're filling in the noise
okay we're feeling a noise so as to uh
basically have the other type not want
to choose that inform experiment because
for the other type he deems these
states not very likely and therefore
this information structure would leave
him very confused as to what the optimal
experiment is
okay so in other words uh in terms of
incentive constraint what this does do
is
it minimizes the type one error
that
the agent incurs that chooses that
experiment okay and it maximizes the
type two error that the other type would
face if you were to try to acquire that
experiment and so that's a sense
in which type 1 and type 2 error show up
here now through
the incentive constraints that we're
providing okay
this is going back to next question so
it looks like you're giving the same
menu of experiments to all the types
so why absolutely why is it enough to
have the same number of
signals as the number of actions
available
because um
all the types have the same set of
actions available
i mean i could extend it and then it's
not that i'm just going to play the
action that you tell me to play like if
i
have a one-to-one mapping between the
signals in action
it's not
that signal will have different content
for different
types
okay it will have different content but
they will know how to interpret it at
the end of the day all they want to do
is to choose one out of the n actions
and that's sort of the the reason uh
that there's this cardinal natural
cardinality restriction
or natural minimal cardinality let me
just conclude with one last okay uh and
so now i want to
basically
give you the coarseness result that is
to say that
the experiment
is simple in the sense that it has a
minimal cardinality but also the menu is
caused relative to the set of choices
available relatively to the diversity in
the types okay and for that we're going
to return to the binary states
but allow a continuum of times okay so
so we could possibly now offer a
continuum of experiments
okay
and the answer and what we're going to
see is that actually the optimal
experiment the optimal menu is going to
have at most two experiments
so it's going to be very coarse
okay
um
all right and so uh yeah
we have only two types now yeah no we
have
two states okay it's a high state or low
state therefore that we think about at
most two actions that are relevant but
the types are now on a continuum between
zero and one which are simply my prior
belief that the state is high okay
so uh so we're going to try to argue
that the optimal mechanism is to offer
at most two experiments in the menu
okay
and um
what i want to indicate here is that
remember we before had the triangle that
we were thinking about the highest type
in the middle and then all the other
types to the left and to the right well
actually
that's precisely the picture also that
arises when you think about incentive
compatibility okay
the net utility information and that we
have to give the high type uh has to be
incentive concept compatible with the
utility that we give to locally the
types below him okay but below him we
can approach him from the left as well
as from the right so that means we're
going to face a constraint now that says
locally the incentive constraints have
to add up to the same thing when we come
from to left to the right okay
so therefore
we basically have a necessary condition
okay that says
if the allocation queue is implementable
and responsive was basically
uh was simply a condition that says
uh that guarantees that the
participation constraint at the low end
at minus 100 plus ones are satisfied
then it ought to be the case that this q
which is simply a difference alpha minus
beta is non-decreasing okay but that the
new condition here this is the integral
conditions which comes from the fact
that the local incentive constraints
have to be matched
is basically giving us this integral
condition that the sum
from zero to one has to add up
to to zero right
so that
basically they have to converge to the
same indirect utility of the mid type
okay
with that
we have sort of a linear problem in
terms of the virtual utility okay
and absence is integral constraint we
would simply have an all or nothing
information structure this is either we
provide full information perfect
information or zero information okay
but because of that integral constraint
we now have to also allow for
intermediate forces us basically to
choose exactly one intermediate solution
okay
and so
that's the result now that an optimal
menu consists of at most two experiments
we will always provide the efficient
experiment the fully informative one
but then the second experiment is one
in which information is degraded
and is both locally non-dispersed and
locally non noise free
okay so that's the sense in which we're
going to provide a course menu because
even though we have a continuum
of types in terms of the prior belief we
are only optimally offering only two
choices
and so
you could ask yourself when is it the
case that i really want to use two and
when is it the case that i'm going to
only provide one
uh well if you have a symmetric
distribution around one half
then basically this adding up constraint
is automatically satisfied and therefore
uh we are basically in a situation where
the integral constraint is always
satisfied and then we're only going to
sell
a um the most efficient experiment
but otherwise we're going to um to use
um further versioning of the experiment
and then in fact it doesn't need to be
the case at the highest type sort of a
classic result in the mechanism design
literature get the efficient allocation
no that depends now on the distribution
of prior information in the population
it could very well be that we bias it
away
okay
and so
the last
sort of open question
uh that we're working on in a moment is
to think about whether this result
uh this coarseness result that we have
proven for for the binary state but the
continuum of type um we believe that
that's true also for the finite side and
finite action version basically by sort
of a bundling argument but
since the potential set of experiments
is quite rich
this seems to be a more difficult
problem than we initially thought it
would be
okay
um so basically i i wanted to give you
um
a first way to think about how we should
package information how we should price
information it was really in a very
stark model where there was no
further interaction among the uh buyers
of information and as the many questions
in the audience pointed out already that
clearly sort of an interesting version
to think about it advertises financial
decision makers when they acquire
information clearly are aware of the
fact that that information
might also have been accessed or used in
one form or the other by competing
decision makers and the question to what
extent that will influence the way i
want to sell information how i want to
package information as sort of an
interesting and open problem
okay
initial
types come
from some common prior and
think of as opposed to just having some
heterogeneous prior beliefs
no actually so you're right for the
for the first result that you saw the
non-dispersants we don't need that
when we then want to derive what is the
the actual
structure of the optimal information
structure how do we want to bias the uh
the less efficient information structure
then we then we use the prior because
that's in a trade-off where the a we
want to offer it and b
in what composition we want the way to
but the fact that i want to be
in some sense at the boundary or the
extreme point of the convex set for that
that that's actually a nice um point to
make uh that's
actually true without the prior and you
would think in many situations you know
the data seller doesn't have a very good
idea of what that prior could possibly
be
a sense of how your results might be
affected if i offer the dynamic menu of
experiments
so i i offer one experiment i observe
the realization then i offer another one
it's a very nice question um no in a
sense it's and that's a question i mean
you know
i'm interested in dynamic problems
dynamic pricing so it's a natural
question
maybe for more than two states so here's
an example right so if you have suppose
the state consists of n binary
attributes
and every types and there are also n
types
and each of them is just missing one of
the attributes
yep
which attribute you're missing
you can probably make it so
excuse me that every type has a
different
valuation for not getting any further
information
and now i can extract
all of their
value by offering each of them
just the one bit that's absolutely not
their values
in some sense you can separate the
problems out along the dimension that's
right exactly and so
now this is giving you a large you know
a menu of size n
and it seems like you need a manual
yes
but the the type space could basically
be an endfold continuum
right and so
right so in each dimension i have now a
posterior whether the attribute is zero
or one and so therefore the type space
can be much richer and my guess is in
the example that you mentioned again we
would it would suffice to basically
offer for each segment a binary
information structure
you're not claiming that you would have
generally only two no no what i'm
claiming is that generally i'm going to
have
finitely many okay and
what the bound is that we have to think
about a little bit um
you